hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen je 2 1 set up tour
und zwar habe ich ja irgendwann mal in
einem video vor zwei wochen oder so
gefragt jetzt geht gerade einfach die
sonne einfach weg ist so ein schönes
wetter ist es richtig blauer himmel
sonne und jetzt schöne dir einfach davon
zwei wochen mal in einem video gefragt
was sie von sommer setup zu erhalten
würde weil ich mir neue tastatur neue
beleuchtung neues mischpult und so
weiter gekauft habe und erneut
bildschirm und so weiter und so fort
habe ich euch mal gefragt was er von
seiner neuen setup equipment erhalten
würde und die meisten meinten du kannst
eigentlich machen deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht ich mach das jetzt einfach mal
und das ist einfach der grund warum wir
gerade nur meine fresse seht und keinen
spiel im hintergrund oder so erst mal so
sieht's aus wenn ich quasi am pc sitzt
dann habe ich hier quasi so hier ist
mein kopf dann habe ich hier so die maus
habe ich dann meine linke hand und hier
mache ich dann irgendwas ihr seht schon
ja das ist apple und ja das ist ein imac
viele meinten aber etwas anderer meinung
und zwar ist dass dieser neue imac
retina 5k mit ganz guter ausstattung und
es läuft zumindest alles super also ich
kann ihn perfekt aufnehmen ihr wisst es
ja minecraft leben mit shader geht alles
klar
internet also damit davon natürlich
nicht abhängig aber läuft auch alles
super und ich kann unter apple einfach
besser arbeiten noch für die uni unseren
diese grafik ich weiß nicht glaub ich
hab ja spotify immer offen
diese grafik ist einfach so unfassbar
toll sieht man jetzt gerade nicht so gut
weil das sich so ein bisschen
reflektiert und da auch ein bisschen
staub drauf ist weil ich nicht so toll
geputzt habe aber ich weiß aber noch
sehen kann aber das ist halt 5k display
und freunde das machte spaß damit zu
arbeiten also das ist schon mal so
meinen pc
ich weiß gar nicht ob ich eine
beschreibung packen kann nicht einfach
mal apple inc oder so ein rein das ist
halt der imac retina 5 k
27 zoll mit 16 gigabyte ram und was hat
der finne grafikkarte wo ich kann man
kurz hier oben kann ich da mal eben kurz
auf über diesen mac klicken dann da da
könnt ihr euch das anschauen was der so
für werther ich weiß es gibt pcs die
haben 32 gigabyte ram und die haben
ideal grafikkarte mit dem und ein
prozessor mit diesem und alles viel
bessere werte aber ich kann einfach mit
apple
ich arbeite damit seit 10.000 millionen
jahren und ich komme damit besser klar
und formlos hättet mich dafür aber ich
komme einfach mit apple besser da klar
also das ist ja eine geschmackssache
gallardo das ist auf jeden fall bald
wird sie dann kommen wir hier auch schon
zu meinem micro einfach weil es immer so
viele fragen in den kommentaren habe ich
das jetzt ja auch immerhin in der
beschreibung stehen das ist dass rohde
nt 1a und das nutze ich seitdem ich mit
youtube angefangen habe ich habe glaube
ich damals mal irgendwann ein headset
mikrofon benutzt aber das war nicht so
toll und das ist halt ein gros membran
mikrofon mono das heißt wenn ihr in
dieser seite rein spricht kommt der ton
scheiße an und hier kommt er gut an fall
sind kurzfassung dann habe ich hier
diese spinne fordert ich habe einfach so
ein konzert gekauft damals aber so alles
dabei da war dass dabei dann dieser
dieser pop schutz hier vorne also die
spinne pop schutz mikrofon dann xlr
kabel dabei und auch ein gelenkarm und
dieser gelenkarm ist eigentlich von
millennium aber den kann man ihnen nicht
mehr kaufen
ich bin mit dem mega zufrieden habe ich
hier angebracht direkt über der marshall
box hier und ich habe euch aber mal eine
beschreibung gepackt den ich mir
wahrscheinlich bald holen werde das ist
eine rote ps 1a heißt er meine
interessen psa 1 also das ist so ein
gelenkarm einfach der ist quasi genauso
also könnt ihr dann das mikrofon einfach
so ein bisschen rum schwenk und ich
hatte halt damals erst so ein stativ
einfach aber das war ein bisschen
sperrig und hiermit kann ich jetzt
einfach sagen ich sie das hier hin oder
hierhin das ist einfach viel viel besser
also der gelenkarm ist eigentlich von
millennium aber ich habe euch einen von
oder eine beschreibung gepackt weil er
einfach nicht mehr geht weil er mir
nicht mehr gebaut wird oder so untergeht
hat das xlr kabel hier raus geht hinter
meinem pc her und kommt dann wenn alles
ein bisschen staubig ist tut mir leid
weil ich eben nicht geputzt habe ich
auch gestern bisschen oder bad geputzt
dann geht das xlr kabel hier vorne rein
dann habe ich nämlich hier schon das
kann ich euch jetzt schon mal zeigen
dass dbx 286 es mike prozessor also die
hat beispielsweise kompressor 3ds was er
noch alles in den henson expander gate
ganz viele sachen ist einfach ein mic
preamp das haben mir freaks lp und komme
glaube ich empfohlen und damit bin ich
mega zufrieden ich muss die einstellung
zwar immer noch ein bisschen optimieren
aber das wird schon noch und da geht das
ganze auf jeden fall erstmal rainer wird
der kompressor oder draufgepackt uns
weiter einfach dass die stimme wenn ich
schreie und wendig leise rede dass ich
weiß du auf einer höhe ist dann geht das
ganze hier über klinke wieder raus und
über xlr dann hier noch mal in mein
behringer 10x 1002 weil ich irgendwie
finde dass wenn das doppelt durch
mischpult hört sich das besser an oder
geht das hier über links rechts links
wieder hier in den computer da mag einen
mikrofoneingang hatte einfach über usb
den usb rein und das passt doch alles
super hört sich ganz passabel an also
kurz was nochmal bezüglich der ganzen
mikrofon aufnahme stimmen aufnahme sache
rohde nt 1a im paket gekauft mit spindel
pop schutz et cetera das ist ein
millenium griff an den gibt's aber nicht
mehr deswegen habe ich euch das rote psa
einzelne beschreibung gepackt dann geht
das überall mehrere xlr kabel und
klinkenkabel hier in das die wx handy
halt's maul in das dx 286 es rein wo das
ganze ein kompressor bekommt die es
weiter und dann nochmal über das
behringer und dann in den einen dann
habe ich hier den ton mit dem ich immer
meine videos aufnehmen an ich zeige euch
einfach mal ein drucker also wir werden
euch nicht ein beschreibung vorliegt
glaube ich bin einfach zufrieden damit
dass es der canon mg 42 50
also darf fragen sich auch mal einige
höhe was ist das hier um steht diesmal
im büro kann da haben wir schon meine
erste videoleuchte die kann ich auch mal
eben hier an machen habe ich nicht hier
sein kabel einfach so zac das ist meine
erste videoleuchte die kommen quasi von
links und von rechts haben wir das hier
dazu komme ich gleich noch mal dass es
nicht was ich mir neu gekauft habe und
da
da bin ich mega zufrieden aber das ist
auf jeden fall erstmal eine ganz normale
videoleuchte also die hat glaube ich
sogar dies 91 20 euro aus japan also da
könnt ihr euch irgendeine kaufen einfach
das ist das ist einfach einfach nur
licht was quasi von links kommt übrigens
falls ihr euch fragt wo diese ganzen
kabel hingehen die ich euch quasi von da
vorne gerade von der softbox oder so
gezeigt habe ich habe ich unter meinem
schreibtisch sonne ganz viele leisten wo
das ganze hingeht und das cool ist ich
habe quasi auf den leisten
die könnt ihr auch einfach überall
kaufen die muss ich euch sich und
verlinken habe ich da so kleine schalter
stehen das heißt wenn ich nur mal den pc
vom strom ausschalten möchte kann ich da
einfach so im verein schalter drücken
dadurch hält mehrere drauf das wusste
ich vorher noch gar nicht dachte es gibt
noch steckerleisten wo man das komplett
alles ausschalten und anschalten kann
aber so finde ich das auf jeden fall
ganz cool also da unten kommt quasi mann
ist meine stromquelle sage ich mal dann
machen wir jetzt mal weiter mit der
anderen video beleuchtung und zwar mit
dieser kleinen hier das ist die junge
hübsche london nur oops i lon n 300 das
ist eine videoleuchte kann man bei
amazon kaufen
und da muss man sich dann halt auch noch
ein kleines stativ zu kaufen da kann ich
auch hier offen machen und dann kann ich
das quasi einfach ein bisschen höher
schieben habe ich das ist jetzt so was
uns unter krachen würde und das ding
auch gerade einfach an ist das hat
eigentlich hat dass hier so viele
platten also wie kann man da vorschieben
und ihr seht schon da sind also kleine
lichter steht man quasi einfach davor
und da gibt's dann da sind andere sachen
baldi nicht nur in weiß sondern auch in
blau in orange und schwarz und so weiter
einfach wenn man verschiedene quellen
verschiedene lichtstärke beziehungsweise
lichtfarben haben möchte ihnen die so
sepia oder er soll dunkel
damit war ich nicht so ganz zufrieden
das licht was dann nämlich rauskam wenn
ich nur diese platte hier drin hätte das
war mir so ein bisschen zu kalt deswegen
habe ich jetzt hier einfach noch so ein
sonst einfach so drüber geklebt so ganz
provisorisch einfach mit tesafilm und
jetzt ist das licht nämlich genau die
passende stärke die ich möchte weil
hiermit war das so richtig grill unsere
und hiermit wird das jetzt ein bisschen
gewinnt und das coole daran ist ich kann
während der aufnahme habe ich hier so
eine fernbedienung und dann kann ich
hier einfach mal sagen du kannst das
ganze ja mal ein bisschen heller machen
oder auch macht das ganze doch mal ein
bisschen dunkler oder mama diesmal da
und da kann ich da auch quasi
verschiedene kameras einfach auswählen
also ich kann zum beispiel sagen
verguckt wir den checks mal anbietet
dunkeln es theoretisch sagt hey ich hab
mal kennen es oder ich hab feiert oder
ich hab nikon oder kilometer das
anscheinend scanner das alles bedeutet
habe ich kann auf jeden fall ihr seien
oft und blabla und so weiter und so fort
das ist eigentlich ganz nice was ich
damit so alles machen kann aber was ich
da ein bisschen auftrieb bz was
eigentlich auch gut ist das ganze ding
hat einen akku das heißt ich muss den
akku abnehmen wenn er ist das hält
irgendwie für zwei stunden oder so dann
packe ich bin einfach hier rein und in
den steckdosen kann ich das ganze halt
aufladen
das ist einerseits natürlich scheiße das
ist teilweise nach aufnahme einfach mal
kann sein dass es einfach so ausgeht
aber für irgendwelche aufnahmen wenn ich
jetzt beispielsweise mich auf meine
couch setzte und lego minecraft
aufgenommen habe konnte ich die quasi
einfach so mitnehmen ohne irgendeine
steckdose zu suchen oder so also das
ganze findet ihr auch in der
beschreibung jung-moo y n 300 und falls
ihr euch bestellt wundert euch nicht die
ganzen anleitungen sind japanische hier
vorne ist einfach meine ps4 falls euch
gefragt habt dass ihr neben steht ist
ihr aufklebers egal jedenfalls einfach
zwei controller ps4 muss ich nicht viel
zu sagen jeder kennt bbs spiel und bis
jetzt auch relativ egal dann haben wir
hier meinen zweiten bildschirm den seht
ihr schon das war mir sehr wichtig dass
ich mit einem neuen kaufe zum umziehen
und zwar durch damals meinem zimmer
hatte ich einen fernseher und halt mein
pc aber jetzt habe ich ja keinen
fernseher mehr deswegen habe ich mir
halt diesen asus ve 278 h gekauft im
namen weiß ich noch ganz genau
und zwar weil das der einzige geile
bildschirm mit guter bewertung in 27
zoll meine ich der und jetzt nicht sagen
haltet euch fest wer ist eigentlich
relativ normal für ein bildschirm ist
aber das war der einzige den ich
gewonnen habt ihr zwei hdmi-anschlüsse
hatte ich erzähle euch jetzt mal die
ganze story und zwar hatte ich halt
damals war sie mal ein pc wo ich die
ganzen sachen gemacht habe und meinen
fernseher wohl drauf ich gezockt habe
aber da ich in meiner wohnung einfach
keinen fernseher brauche weil ich eine
aktion die fernsehen gucke und alles
mögliche wie zirkus halligalli oder
fußball kann auch live stream schauen
und ein serien bei netflix und so weiter
habe ich mir gedacht ich brauche und
brauchen monitor den ich einerseits als
zweiter monitor für den imac benutzen
kann aber auch als quasi quelle
als bildquelle für meine playstation
wenn freunde da sind wir zocken wollen
deswegen habe ich monitor gesucht der
einerseits zwei hdmi-anschlüsse hatte
also nehm einen ist quasi der pc drin
und dann kann ich hier einfach
umschalten über diesen einen knopf und
dann wird die playstation daran
aktiviert und dann habe ich noch ein
gesucht der einen lautsprecher hat und
er hat einen lautsprecher ist 27 zoll
hat eine gute grafik eine gute bewertung
und hat zwei hdmi-anschlüsse deswegen
bin ich mit dem mega zufrieden mit dem
von von asus aces kanal wieder
gesprochen wird der heißt asus v2 sie
macht h ist auch in der beschreibung
kann ich jedem nur empfehlen diesen
monitor ich bekomme dafür übrigens
nichts und würde die irgendwo sehen
übrigens viele sagen immerhin marcel
duclaud placement produkt vorstellt
freunde welche product placement mache
dann steht das ihnen von der
beschreibung oder irgendwo war das
angeben muss also hinterher verstehen
man das einfach nur weil ich damit
zufrieden wenn mit den sachen ihr müsst
euch den scheiß nicht kaufen aber ich
bin damit zufrieden
dann kommen jetzt auch zur schon zu den
letzten sachen meine maus ist die razer
mamba die hat bei amazon totale scheiß
bewertung aber ich bin damit zufrieden
also ich nutze die mittlerweile seit ihr
seht doch schon da sind so mega viele
staub sache mittlerweile drin ich musste
eigentlich mal saubermachen
ich nutze ich schon seit 23 jahren oder
so ich weiß der hübschen so lange
draußen ist auf jeden fall seitdem ich
hier wohne auf jeden fall schon und
schon noch länger das ist eigentlich
eine eine kabellose maus habe ich nutze
immer mit kabel weil keine ahnung und
damit bin ich eigentlich ganz zufrieden
weil das eigentlich einfach mal im maus
ist wo ich mich quasi einfach so meine
hand drauf legen kann komplett ich finde
die anderen mäuse sind alle so komisch
wäre ich also mit dass die razer mamba
dann hab ich meine neue tastatur gekauft
das ist die roccat kulo ich hatte vorher
die isku aber die ist bei mir einfach
kaputt gegangen einfach ein paar tasten
aufgehört zu funktionieren
deswegen habe ich mir dann gedacht ich
hole immer die reihe sam kerkloh bin ich
auch ganz gut mit zufrieden ist eine
mechanische tastatur und die hört man
auch teilweise meinen aufnahmen beim ein
mikrofon hat quasi mal hier ist und
meint an tastatur direkt hier und
deswegen hört man das direkt weil die
ist auch relativ laut wenn ich immer so
das ist schon relativ der meckert gratis
ein bisschen übrig was auch ganz cooles
an männer
total synchronisiert einfach mit meinem
handy das heißt wenn ich beispielsweise
irgendwelche in welche sachen habe die
gleich anstehen oder so dann informierte
mich da direkt rüber wunders könnte so
eine cloud synchronisation quasi nie
aufbauen müssen heute kann das gerät das
ich möchte nicht sagen kauft euch ein
apple weil ich bekomme dafür nichts wenn
ich ein produkt mit apple hätte dann
will ich glaube ich kann youtube machen
aber ich bin damit zufrieden aber ich
möchte einfach nicht dass freunde sagen
einfach haye der eine total scheiße also
das ist die tastatur das ist eine
mechanische riace im klo und die letzte
sache ich mein webcam jay den jackpot
oder webcam ist die logitech 10 920
damit bin ich eigentlich mega zufrieden
nur wenn ihr euch die also dies vom bild
nahezu geiler als die kennen
eos 600d die ich damals mal hatte und
kostet 70 jahre oder so nur sag ich mal
schon vier filme webcam
aber die hat eine mega geile qualität
ist über usb angeschlossen die streiche
die hier liegt irgendwo als einzige
problem bei der sache ist wenn man damit
quasi so videoaufnahmen macht dann wird
das einander zeit asynchron also man
muss die in punkt mv abspeichern das ist
ein kleiner insidertipp der mir von
spiele trend gegeben wurde
also das ist meine webcam und das war es
dann auch eigentlich schon oder dass ich
meine das war alles meinem monitor mein
normales mischpult mein kompressor
mischpult meine tastatur eine maus meine
webcam eine jung moo videoleuchte rechts
mal eine ganz normale noname
videoleuchte links meine ja einfach so
ne lampe ihr habe ich einfach stehen
mein telefon und mein drucker meinen
rohde ende 1 am mikrofon mikrofonarm
mein pc und das war erfreulich hoffe ich
konnte euch damit irgendwie weiterhelfen
also viele hatten ja gefragt hat sie
probleme hat man nicht schuldig das
gelöst habe und als meine tastatur
kaputt war und so weit ich habe ein paar
neue sachen gekauft weil ich finde diese
ganze kacke wenig dahinter schneiden
muss und dann muss das zurück sein ob
blabla ich einfach keinen bock drauf
weil ich eh neue sachen braucht und
leser ein bisschen geschwächelt habe
mein equipment habe ich mir dann einfach
ein bisschen neue sachen geholt die
single investiert und das habe ich euch
jetzt einfach mal gezeigte findet links
in der beschreibung ich würde mich meine
bewertung euren demonstriert